[Musique]
soir les enfants
nos petits amis sont bien silencieux ce
soir ro le jury ils sont déjà couchés
jeter son lait voir sur la pointe de
pâtes dont le cheval
au bond
alors d'accord
mais cachez vous vite
mais toi sur les toits m'enfin derrière
les rideaux du tout au tout les temps on
peut voter oui
[Musique]
gentil tout
bonsoir monsieur petit je vois que vous
n'êtes pas encore couchés humaine
heureux ils dorment des gens tu ne les a
pas vus nounours où ils sont parqués à
ta rencontre à ma rencontre
oui ce matin voir leurs tentes ont bien
aimé ce matin
ce matin très tôt enfin rémi toto ou
qu'il plus âgés mais que cherche le
pauvre petit tout seul dans les rues
mais cet affreux
emilia au long surtout pas que du réel
elle qui m'a confié ses petits enfants
chéris ils sont peut être perdu à
l'heure qu'il est mes chers petits
neveux courage ne se laisse pas abattre
tentant courage courage je vais demander
conseil à mon patron téléphonons
étoiles l'audi cola je n'ai plus étoiles
fait le
380 si ça te fait plaisir
000 voix
merci halle aux marchands de sable ces
nounours j'ai des ennuis mais ne le sont
plus chez nicolas et pimprenelle
as tu bien cherché nounours
pas encore mais vous battre on est dans
la maison nigo oh vous croyez
excusez moi on me chatouille les pieds
une petite souris je veux la voir de
plus près
fury ou li petite souris mais maintenant
je vais attraper les ont
alors vous inquiétez pas je crois qu'on
aimerait se retrouver au revoir petits
machins
à l'eau va rejoindre son frère
lui apprenait les dicos là on les p'tits
drôles
[Musique]
il en manque encore 1
alors tu les as retrouvé mes neveux
chéri non il en manque encore un
bâton
quand ford et de souffler
[Musique]
même bien attraper c'est la dernière
fois que vous m'attraper du demain je
ramènerai mes neveux chez leur maman
ballon en dormez-vous vite
hollerich
[Musique]
allons-nous nours dépêche-toi nous
sommes en retard
patron or 16 enfants
il ment n'ont encore fait voir mais
est-ce que je les ai bonne nuit les
petits faites pour
[Musique]
où